[Music]
a father is searching for answers while
mourning the loss of his teenage son
police say the teen was shot in the head
by a man walking his dog but they also
say it was in self-defense this happened
back in april in the foothills community
near flamingo and fort apache and there
are no arrests victoria saha joins us
live in our newsroom with this eight
news now exclusive
brian and denise good evening to you
both today we're learning 16 year old
christian murphy was shot in the back of
the head allegedly by a neighbor walking
his dog when this incident first
happened police told us christian had a
gun on him but now his dad says given
his son was shot from behind his killing
is not justifiable
this is really really really tough as a
father
it's a mutual son phillip murphy is
struggling to find the answers as to why
a neighbor pulled the trigger on his son
he shot my child in the back of the head
and
he needs to he needs to be punished for
it on the morning of april 11th murphy
says christian and his older brother got
into an argument christian took his
brother's gun and went outside the two
continued arguing when a neighbor
walking his dog got involved neighbor
that lives on the next street over from
where my kids grew up at to try to tell
them to get on the ground i don't know
why he thought that
it was right to take it in his own hands
and act as a police officer murphy says
both of his sons got onto the ground but
then his older son realized this man
wasn't a cop and ran back in leaving
just christian on the ground complying
seconds later there was a shot fire
my son had his back turned to get a
bullet in the back of that police say
the neighbor was acting in self-defense
there's no just justifying
self-defense when a bullet goes through
the back your head they claim christian
was shooting at people before he was
shot we went to the neighbor's house to
get his side of the story but were
turned away i'm going to get answers i'm
going to fight for my son i'm going to
get answers and i'm not done
christian was taken to the hospital
where doctors determined the bullet
caused too much damage and his father
had to take him off of life support
although there haven't been any arrests
or charges police say they're still
continuing their investigation and the
case still needs to go through the
district attorney's office brian
victoria thank you for that